Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. No else.
You would pose a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue over another.
This episode is brought to you by
gymnastic bodies.com this is the training
system that I am most obsessed with
at the moment and I don't get paid any
commissions or anything like that.
You may have heard coach summer on
the podcast who designed the program,
former national team coach
for men's gymnastics.
I am not easily impressed and I've
just been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming
and the elegance of his programming.
I've been using gymnastic bodies for
just a few months now and I feel more
flexible,
stronger and younger than I have in
years and it sounds cheesy to hear myself
say that,
but it's true.
That's the hardest part to
believe and you can check it out.
Gymnastic bodies.com forward slash.
Tim, if you go to that landing page,
gymnastic bodies.com forward slash Tim
you can take a look at the fundamentals
course, which will help you diagnose
your weakest points, areas to improve,
et Cetera,
and I highly encourage you take a look
at this bodyweight training system.
It is incredible.
Gymnastic bodies.com forward slash Tim.
Yeah.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic.
I reached out to these
Finnish entrepreneurs after
a very talented acrobat,
introduced me to one of their products,
which blew my mind and the best
way possible it is mushroom coffee.
What on earth is this? Well,
it includes Chaga mushroom,
very powerful antioxidant,
considered a super food.
I was introduced to
Chaga by Laird Hamilton,
the King of Big Wave Surfing of all things
and it includes another mushroom that
is considered a no tropic,
a smart drug and this is lion's
mane in the entire packet.
You just add it to hot water.
Tastes like coffee.
There is only 40 milligrams of caffeine,
so less than half what you
would find in a cup of coffee.
So I do not get any jitters.
I do not get any acid reflux or any type
of stomach burn and it put me on fire
for an entire day and I
only had half of the packet.
So this stuff is really amazing.
People are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement right now.
This is the answer. So it is legal.
It will not give you visuals.
That's something else,
and you can try it right now by going to
foursigmatic.com forward slash Tim that
is for Sig Madec, s I, g m,
a t I c foursigmatic.com forward slash
Tim and use the Code Tim to get 20% off
your first order.
If you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed.
foursigmatic.com forward slash
hello
ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
each episode I deconstruct a world class
performer to tease out the rituals,
routines, habits, purchasing decisions,
et Cetera, that you can emulate,
test in your own life, whether they are
from athletics, entertainment, business,
military or otherwise.
This episode is a round two with dom
D'Agostino dom that is doctor Dominic
D'agostino is an assistant professor in
the department of Molecular Pharmacology
and physiology at the
University of South Florida.
Morsani College of medicine and that
is a mouthful and a senior research
scientist at the Institute for
human and machine cognition IHMC.
He's also dead,
lifted 500 pounds for 10
reps after a seven day fast
and I consider him a friend.
I call him,
he's on speed dial for me with many of
my metabolic and nutritional questions
and many,
many of you after the last,
I think it was two to two and a half
hour conversation with dom and if you
haven't heard that you can go to four
hour work week.com forward slash dom dom
and it will take you to that URL.
After that episode,
he and I were just delusion
with enthusiastic followup
questions about Ketosis,
ketones, cancer, et cetera.
The following is dom answering your
most popular questions with a particular
focus on ketones, ketosis,
ketogenetic diet, et cetera.
And for that reason you could consider
it the sort of Ketosis masterclasses,
especially if you combine both episodes.
But this one stands alone
if you want to listen to it.
There are a couple of things that are
not mentioned at length, uh, necessarily.
We're in detail.
For instance,
the types of canned sardines
and oysters that he eats,
King Oscar and wild planet foods.
This is from the first episode in the
show notes is where you can find the
sardines.
It's also why whole foods around the
country sold out of wild planet food.
Sardines is this episode and then the
canned oysters would be crowned Prince
Natural Oysters,
but you can find all of that in the
show notes@fourhourworkweek.com forward
slash dom for the first episode.
And we cover a lot.
And what I would suggest is
dom did this on the road.
It takes a few minutes for him
to get warmed up, be patient,
listened to it. And if you want to skip
around, I mean there are a few things,
for instance around I believe
eight minutes, 55 seconds,
let's just call it nine
minutes after this intro ends.
Can you gain muscle on the ketogenic diet
and a related questions around 52 and
20 seconds after this intro. How does
he handle travel? What does he pack?
And if you're really considering exploring
ketosis or just consuming exogenous
ketones like the Kido Kana and Quito force
that I've discussed with dom and also
with Patrick Arnold, very
famous biochemist for
performance enhancing compounds,
shall we say.
Uh,
then this is also relevant because there
is data to suggest that you can slow,
for instance, tumor growth by consuming
these synthetic exogenous ketones.
Even if you are still consuming
glucose or producing glucose,
which is very, very exciting for
all sorts of reasons. In any case,
this is going to be dense. It's going
to be worth it and just be patient. And,
uh, I think that if you have an interest
in these types of metabolic therapies,
whether it is for performance enhancement
and let's say endurance or for
anticancer purposes or otherwise,
that you will find a gem
within this conversation,
which is more of a monologue I suppose.
So please enjoy this
conversation with dom D'Agostino.
If you want to say hello to him,
you can certainly do so on Twitter.
It's imagine that at
Dominic d, O m I n I c. Dot.
Agastein o d a g o s t,
I and then the number two,
I guess it was t Dominic
D'Agostino has taken.
So at Dominic d a gusty to is his Twitter.
And that will also be in the show notes.
Uh,
you can find all show notes at [inaudible]
four hour work week.com forward slash
podcast. And what a fucking long
intro. I'm sorry folks. Enjoy
first question, uh, is still be
under the ketogenic diet category.
Under that court category is also some
questions on fasting. I think Alex,
David writes,
despite all the evidence,
it seems that many Dietitians
and researchers, uh,
I'd had a clinicians to that
still frown heavily on Ketosis.
Why is there so much resistance?
So I think the main reason would be
the lack of education in the medical
community and even in
the dietetics programs.
So having gone through and nutrition
science program in my Undergrad,
um, 20 so years ago, uh,
there was a little bit of
discussion on low carb diets,
very little if any discussion
about a key to genic diet.
There was a discussion,
uh,
kind of a negative discussion one
day I remember on the actins Diet.
So my particular professor at the
time really sort of spies that tie.
So that's the problem. Like, you know,
registered dieticians who were
supposed to be at the cusp, the, the,
the front of,
of understanding sort of nutrition and
how to manipulate nutrition for optimum
health or weight loss.
And most of the patients that they deal
with are really trying to lose weight or
manage type two diabetes.
And we know the ketogenic diet is like a,
a big hammer,
you know,
for type two diabetes is Jeff Volak
would say put it type two diabetic
intermission within like two weeks or so.
You could see that,
you know,
that that's known.
I think the big stigma comes from the
dietetic community is that it's just not
feasible for people to follow.
And you know,
if you lower the carbs, what type
of macro nutrient are you adding?
You're adding fat, right in.
Saturated fat has been demonized.
Certainly it was demonized
back when I was in, in college,
you know,
over 20 years ago.
And that's going to be hard to change.
I think our stance on that
has softened up considerably,
but it's going to take some time to
change the minds of the people who are the
major influencers,
which would be kind of the medical
community and dietetic program.
They need to accept that the low carb
ketogenic diet really has a place.
And right now it's really doesn't have a
place. Uh, it's getting more attention,
which is good, but it doesn't have a
place in the medical community too.
So the lack of education there.
I teach in the medical
college and I'm on the,
I was on the medical curriculum committee
for medical school for a number of
years, like three years. And the,
the curriculum is already so compressed
and it's tries to fit in as much as
possible.
The information is sort of biased if
you want to say that towards covering
what's on the, the boards that
the medical students have to take.
The U s Emily.
So they,
there's just no room to fit in
nutrition into the medical curriculum.
So doctors are not going to have
an appreciation of nutrition.
There's certainly not going to have an
appreciation for the ketogenic diet.
So the medical school that I teach at
though does have a functional medicine
sort of group of kids that are very
enthusiastic and really smart and they,
they really want this
information and they have a,
a lunch sort of seminar series that they
have people come in and talk and I've
given a talk and my students,
uh,
are research associates
have given a talk in this.
And the feedback has been really good.
I mean they,
they want the information but it's just
not taught in the general curriculum.
And it needs to be.
So nutrition is really the
foundation of our health. And uh,
and if medicine wants
to focus on prevention,
there's no better tool than nutrition.
Exercise helps,
but probably not as good as nutrition.
So nutrition research too.
There's just a,
a lack of good research on low carb diets.
The ketogenic diets are sun
out there if you look, but the,
the rigorous sort of controlled
multi university trials,
looking at the effects of a high
carb diet verse Mediterranean verse,
low carb or Ketogenic Diet.
These are really difficult studies
to do and they're really expensive.
And uh, you know, it comes,
you have the question of who's
going to fund these studies?
What kind of institutional support
do you have to run these studies?
Are The people at the
institute knowledgeable?
Do they have a team of Dietitians that
can control the parameters that are
needed to ensure a diet compliance,
for example,
are they measuring blood ketones for all
the participants in the Ketogenic Diet
Group? So that rarely happens.
And that's the kind of,
you know,
oversight that needs to happen to
be able to do this kind of research.
And um,
you know,
the research is really going to be
important because that's what the medical
community who are not taught nutrition,
that's what they're going to look at.
They're going to want evidence
so that they say, you know,
if you tell them that this is a
powerful metabolic therapy and even the
standards of care for drug
resistant or refractory epilepsy,
it works remarkably well
for that application.
And I think it can work equally well
for a number of other applications.
They're going to want that,
the research to support that.
And I think that research is in progress
and I think the low hanging fruit would
be looking at type two
diabetes and obesity.
And I think that's going to be one of
the most important applications for a key
to genic or maybe not even
KeyJack low carb diet.
So a low carb diet is
relatively easy to do,
but nutritional ketosis is considered
really considered extreme and difficult to
implement. Right? So that's why, you know,
the question is why are researchers
or dieticians frowning on this?
So it dietician is gonna have
a difficult job getting their,
their patients to comply with this kind
of diet. And I could just tell you,
buy people come to me and uh,
many of them that attempt the
Ketogenic Diet just can't follow it.
It's really hard to follow.
And that's what I think something
like a modified Atkins Diet,
you'll get four times the
amount of compliance. Uh,
if you can get maybe 10% of people
that can follow a ketogenic diet,
I would say if you screen them properly,
you can get at least 40% of the people
to adhere to and modify ketogenic diet
defined as sort of following in a way
that they consistently have an elevation
of blood ketones day in and day out.
So it's just a much easier diet to follow.
Talk a little bit more about that.
A leader I think with questions and
there's also some resistance from the
exercise community too. Um, if
people, the question is what do you,
what are you using the Ketogenic Diet for?
And there's clearly saw on social media,
there's a lot of talk and discussion
and debate about the ketogenic diet for
endurance athletes,
long distance runners.
And I think it definitely
has an application.
They're bigger question that I get a lot.
Is it the ideal diet or can you
gain muscle size and strength,
you know, doing resistance
training, doing bodybuilding power,
lifting with a ketogenic diet. And
I think you can, I know you can,
uh, the question is,
you know, is it optimal?
Probably not for everybody,
but I think it is for,
I think it can be for a
subpopulation of people.
And I think, you know, as we age,
our carbohydrate tolerance
decreases with age.
So the,
the over 40 crowd and I would fit into
that response remarkably well to a
ketogenic diet, I think in the context of
resistance training or a low carb diet.
But we really need more research on that.
So hopefully we're, we plan to do that.
So, um, uh, the next question probably
spent too long on that question,
so I'll try to hit these more rapid fire.
The next question comes from Grad Gross.
Could you please ask him
about protein intake, uh,
on,
on Ketosis.
So it seems like there's a thousands
of different answers out there to this
question.
And yes,
everybody's got an answer to how much
protein you should take on a ketogenic
diet.
So in the case of me and then the case
in the context of treating kids with
epilepsy,
it's been found that keeping your protein
between one and 1.5 grams per kilogram
per day is really,
you need to kind of stay within that
range to consistently stay in nutritional
ketosis as protein is can be insulinogenic
so you could excess protein can feed
into gluconeogenic pathway and kick you
out of Ketosis or decrease your ketone
levels.
Um,
so I would say the higher protein though
is probably needed in people that are
more active and also heavy training.
And I think when you get the person
who's an ectomorph and is super fast
metabolism and maybe on top
of that, you know, from mine,
he's an Ectomorph and he has a very
high output, you know, cause he,
he works outside all day so he
needs two grams per kilogram day.
And that would,
that's typically far above what most
people would take for a ketogenic diet.
But his ketones stave remarkably high
off fat cause its output is really high.
Uh, typical ketogenic diet, quote
unquote, the classical ketogenic diet,
a four to one ratio, four parts
fat, one part combination protein,
carbs has like 10% calories coming
from protein that's really low.
So a modified ketogenic diet is 25 to
30% calories and protein from protein
percentage protein. And that's also
called the modified Atkins Diet. And, uh,
it really evolved out of work done
at Johns Hopkins. Uh, Eric Kossoff.
Uh,
it was probably the leader in sort
of advancing the modified Atkins as a
metabolic therapy for, for uh,
kids and adults with the seizures.
And that's really the Diet that,
that a lot of athletes are using.
So my,
myself included kind of not an athlete,
but I think most of the people who say
they're on a ketogenic diet are not doing
the classical ketogenic diet,
which is like 10% protein.
So yeah,
the protein intake,
very general recommendation,
one to 1.5 grams per kilogram.
Matt Nelson Ass.
The impact of the Ketogenic
Diet on type one diabetes.
So it's an interesting situations that
I have a type one diabetic student in my
lab and he's a phd student. Remarkable
student, Vic guys, six, four,
250. Uh, Andrew Coot.
Nick is his name and join the lab with
an intense interest in this subject and
took it upon himself to try the
ketogenic diet as a type one diabetic.
Right? So, um,
he tracks everything including his blood
glucose continuously cause he has one
of the,
uh,
sort of Dex con units that continuously
measures his blood glucose levels.
And,
um,
he's a remarkable subject for testing
ketogenic food products because we could
just turn his insulin off so he has a
glucose monitoring system and an insulin
pump.
If we want to examine the glycaemic
index or the glycaemic response,
I guess you would say at different foods,
we can use Andrew and turn off his, uh,
his insulin pump and then look at his,
uh,
glycaemic response to the food.
So it comes in very handy. Uh,
so Andrew,
uh,
is a great sport and he decided to try
the Ketogenic Diet and his written up
some notes here that things just
sort of describing his response to,
to the Diet.
And Andrew kind of is very,
um, kind of perceptive about
many different things, including,
uh,
his insulin sensitivity.
So he has a really good handle on
how changes in his body composition,
his exercise.
So when he does kind of brutal
exercises training in the gym, uh,
the frequency that consistency,
uh, how that affects his,
his blood glucose,
that type of insulin that he uses and
how that influences his caffeine use is
fiber, the composition of
his meal, the types of foods,
what he adds to his foods,
things like cinnamon.
So he's tracked like all
these different variables and,
and how these variables influence his
blood glucose and the amount of insulin
that he needs.
When he got around to the Ketogenic Diet,
he realized there was some really big
perks to being a type one diabetic and
being on a kid Jank Diet.
And the biggest would be the lack
of blood glucose fluctuations.
So tremendous difference between a in
glucose fluctuations on a high carb diet
versus the Ketogenic Diet.
The daily fluctuations were remarkably
tighter and he's been conversing with
other type two diabetics who have
switched from the Diet that they have been
prescribed and the
ketogenic diet. And, um,
I mean it's, it's amazing the, uh,
the control of blood glucose that you
have when you're on a ketogenic diet and
not only is your blood glucose,
his blood glucose,
remarkably a kind of controlled
when he switched to ketogenic diet,
but he was able to reduce
his insulin levels, uh,
to about one third of the amount of
insulin that he was using before.
So whenever you can reduce the amount of
insulin for a type one diabetic can do
that, that's a good thing. So, um,
doctors need to acknowledge
that. So he, uh,
had a similar reduction
in 24 hour insulin levels,
uh,
or no hidden in his notes here.
He noted that there was a similar
reduction in 24 hour insulin levels,
uh, reported in individuals
who were underweight, uh,
who underwent and ketogenic diet,
but maintain body weight. So,
and he lists a number of different
publications to support sort of the same
observation that he saw when he switched
from a high carb diet to a ketogenic
diet for managing his type one diabetes.
Uh, his insulin sensitivity
increase tremendously.
So in this has major implications,
uh,
potential protection against
hypoglycemia, right? Uh,
in my talks, I always talk
about the work of, uh,
George Cahill from Harvard in 1967 and
the mid sixties and 1967 he published
then observation fastest subjects who
when adapted to a state of starvation,
ketosis were remarkably resilient
against insulin induced hypoglycemia.
Uh,
so they suppressed their blood glucose
levels with ivy infuse insulin down to
something between one to 2 million molar.
And that would be kind of universally,
if not fatal,
would put someone into a
coma or a seizure. So, uh,
and we know that having blood ketones
elevated make you remarkably protected
against hypoglycemia.
So that has real practical
consequences from a safety standpoint.
Uh, if you're driving, you know,
how many accidents are caused by,
uh, or result from hypoglycemia
and people who are diabetic.
So that much of that could probably be
mitigated if they were on a ketogenic
diet.
So these benefits,
and he described many benefits,
you know,
in our daily talks in the lab and these
benefits essentially eliminate the
potential downside of type one diabetes.
Uh, initially the short term
and the long term, right?
So short term you're talking,
you know,
acute hypoglycemia,
mitigating that is really
important but also the long term.
So if you're on a high carbohydrate
diet and you have huge postprandial
excursions in your blood glucose,
that's gonna and you do that repeatedly,
that that's gonna cause a lot of
harm, you know, in the longterm.
And that can be completely eliminated
or significantly attenuated in type one
diabetics using a low carb approach
or a ketogenic diet approach.
So I noticed a controversial subject
and I don't want to kind of base my
comments or suggestions
off, you know, the,
the people that communicate to me and
seeing firsthand what it did to Andrew who
not only has much better control over
is type one diabetes but is incredibly,
has incredible amount of muscle and
strength and continues to surpass a lot of
his lifts in the gym while following
a ketogenic diet or low carb approach.
So He's more or less transitions from a
ketogenic diet to low carb and kind of
bounces back and forth then stay,
keep genic all the time now.
But he told me that he feels best while
he's on a ketogenic diet and certainly
uses much less insulin.
So there's some resources
out there to point people to,
cause I do get about at least one
or two questions are week on this.
I would point people to the ketogenic
diet for type one diabetes ebook and
that's on ketogenic diet resource.com
and the authors of those books are Ellen
Davis and Dr. Keith Runyan.
And I knew doctor Runyon has been on
several podcasts talking about his use key
is a type one diabetic. He's a
medical doctor with type one diabetes.
Next question I want to address is
by Oh Himba narco swath and asked the
question kenogenic breath
analyzer versus blood.
So which one,
which one's best here?
So the blood glucose slash
ketone meter by Abbott labs,
the precision Xtra and one that I
use personally is the freestyle Neal,
I think it's called.
It's really the gold standard if you're
getting into this and you want to,
if you're not on a tight budget,
I would recommend measuring every day if
you're really serious and to do it the
same time of day every day.
And I think that's really important.
And the breath acetone meter,
uh,
that would be the,
the ketone tonics meter is really
useful and it just really needs more
development and testing
from my perspective. Um,
so we know from at least, you know, one,
maybe two studies breath acetone
levels correlate with seizure control.
So I think if you have kids that are
managing a disorder and they don't want to
be their fingers, you know,
prefer not to be pricked.
I think these breath acetone
meters are great for kids.
And I've talked to,
you know,
parents and kids that enjoy doing them.
Kids you blow in and you have
like these pretty colors.
You get the blue and with low ketones
are green and then orange and yellow I
think in red. So they're
very convenient, uh,
for giving you a range of breath
acetone that can correlate with seizure
control. So I think more work needs
to be sort of done with them. Um,
they're noninvasive and I think there's
what I'm interested in and is actually
using these devices to look at other
volatile organic compounds that may be
important. Health biomarkers
for example. You know,
it gives you information
on oxidative stress,
so you have things like Iso Cross Danes,
uh,
things that could detect from what I'm
interested in is like oxygen toxicity,
pulmonary oxygen toxicity,
uh,
will kind of be characterized by blowing
off certain Baltara organic compounds.
And I think our gut microbiome
to influence the gut
microbiome will influence
the volatile organic compounds
that are coming out of our mouth.
And I think these things can be picked up.
And once we understand and we can develop
devices to measure these things in our
breath and I think don't, no
one has done it yet, but I,
I don't know why it's not possible,
but saliva ketone measurements,
I think that might be, you
know, something to look into.
So if anyone out there is listening,
so maybe a saliva ketone
measurement system could be useful.
The next question is Jeff
Henderson and he writes,
I'd be really curious about how ketosis
affects performance at altitude.
So I live in big sky,
Montana,
do a lot of back country ski touring,
climbing mountaineering.
I've noticed a significant
performance increase while in ketosis.
I'm currently trying to get in a friend's
willing to do a ketogenic diet so I
can put together an actual experiment
with a decent sized Dataset.
So I don't know what he
measure. If he did that. Uh,
we'd love to hear dumps
thoughts on this. Okay. Um,
so there's any increase in brain
blood flow when you are in a state of
nutritional ketosis.
So that may reverse some of the,
the things that we know happen as
a response to altitude. There's,
uh, some individuals can have hypo
Kapnik cerebral vasoconstriction,
so that could maybe be reversed
or mitigated in part, uh,
with nutritional ketosis,
there's also things like, uh,
at altitude you can have an increased
intercranial pressure and uh,
the Diet actually has, uh, uh,
well-described diuretic effect.
It's fairly mild,
but it can maybe reduce
some of the intercranial
pressure that people at really
high altitudes can experience.
So we know too that, uh,
the energy production and our,
our bodies in general probably
can generate energy more
efficiently with ketones
than it can with other types of
fuels with glucose in particular.
And then we can probably derive
more energy per oxygen molecule.
And I would probably direct you to some
of the work that was done by Richard
Veech is lab.
And they did work with a working profused
heart preparation and they looked at
the delta g of ATP hydrolysis and they
look at the hydraulic efficiency of the
heart, which increased
significantly when, uh,
the preparation was perfused
with ketones relative to glucose.
Right?
So there's also a book written by Andrew
Murray and Hugh Montgomery and that
book, the title of it, uh,
how wasting is saving weight loss at
altitude might result from an evolutionary
adaptation.
So this will kind of describes
how nutritional ketosis
may mitigate some of the
weight loss that's associated
with being at altitude.
Peter at Tia also give a talk,
if I remember correctly at Ihmc,
if you Google Peter Tia Ihmc lecture,
he gave a discussion on the performance
enhancement as facts that he had with
the Ketogenic Diet and also
describes cycling at high altitude.
Uh,
I think the balance of the data from a
scientific perspective and from feedback
that I get would suggest that being in
a state of Ketosis can enhance exercise
performance at altitude.
Another person I think communicating
with recently is Patrick Sweeney. Uh,
he t he actually recently teamed up
with Professional Mountain biker.
Rebecca Rush I think is her name.
And they did a climb and descend a on
Mount Kilimanjaro on their mountain bikes.
Right?
So this was a mountain bike climb and the,
the mission was totally self supported,
meaning that they didn't have any porters
to carry their bags or anything and
they didn't, they abstained from
using, uh, see it as old mine,
which is diamox the medication
that you take for altitude.
And so they didn't get altitude sickness.
So the goal of what they're trying to do,
Patrick Sweeney and we're bucket brush,
the goal of the expedition was to raise
$1 for every foot of climbing they did.
So that amounted to a little over
$19,000 for an organization called world
bicycle relief.
And Patrick had communicated with me
prior to attempting this Mount Kilimanjaro
bike ride and uh,
and it kind of coached him a little bit
and just talked about the Ketogenic Diet
and how you do it and sent
a number of emails. Um,
just Google Patrick Sweeney bike ride
and should bring you probably to this
event and get,
gives you more information on it.
And the next question is from
Lindsey Watkins in Z ass.
I'd like to hear about any
differences or considerations females,
uh,
need to have with the ketogenic diet.
So what I've observed is that,
uh,
and this may even apply
to our rodent models, uh,
the transition into ketosis can be
more difficult for females in general.
It seems that they're more
variable in their responses.
Reactive, I would say to low blood
glucose levels, especially initially.
And I would recommend that a female's
trying this sort of ease into it,
uh,
before just going all out ketogenic.
And so it was slow transition
into a ketogenic diet,
maybe dropping your
carbohydrates if you're at 200
down to 150 and just do it in
50 gram increments and titrating it down.
Another option would be the use
of exogenous ketones. You know,
when you go on a ketogenic diet,
your brain goes through what I'd call
glucose withdrawal effects and you might
be able to fill that gap initially
until your body starts making ketones.
Upregulating the transport
and utilization of ketones.
You might be able to fill that gap by
taking exogenous ketones are just simply
using something like
medium chain triglyceride.
The C eight would be the kind of
the most key to genic fat out there.
Another issue that females run into is
that when a lot of women start this,
they tend to start a ketogenic
diet in a calorie deficit.
So they go right into a calorie
restricted ketogenic diet.
So you have sort of the double
whammy. You have, uh, no glucose,
very little glucose getting to the brain
and then calorie restriction on top of
a radical shift in macro
nutrient profile of their diet.
And so that they're going to get
a reactive response from that
hypoglycemia. And, uh,
in some women it can manifest itself
in a strange ways from fainting to
irritability to foggy headedness.
Um,
so the idea would be,
my suggestion would be to keep your,
your calories actually higher
when you start QT tank diet.
So you want a calorie surplus at least
initially to help with the transition
that's high in fat to do,
not as hard for some people,
especially in the fitness industry
when they started to Jank by it,
they have to be, uh, not
afraid of eating fat.
So, you know, a hundred
grams of fat per day.
It is really not a lot of fat.
Some getting upwards of about 200,
250,
300 even on some days.
So for the average size female,
you want to get at least a
hundred grams of fat upwards to,
you know,
depending on your size and your output,
maybe even up to 200 grams of fat.
That would be my suggestions there
to help with with females. Uh,
now the hormonal changes that have been
reported by some females following a
ketogenic diet,
suppression of thyroid.
So I'm just looking through my
emails here, different females. Uh,
yeah,
that seems to be sort of the,
one of the major concerns, uh,
when I probe a little deeper,
the people that are getting,
you know,
a suppression of some of their hormones,
they're exercising a minimum of two,
sometimes four,
six hours a day training for an event.
So the scenario that you have is you're
transitioning your body to a new diet,
high carb to low carb on
top of calorie restriction.
Do you do have an energy deficits that's
caused by a restriction of calories,
it appears.
And also overtraining and
overtraining is the fastest way to,
uh, to really kick down your hormones. Uh,
for males,
manifest is low testosterone.
For females it can manifest
in many different ways.
Most the thing that I see most
is a reduction and t three.
So the next question comes
from Cammie Orion and she asks,
can a female obtain a sub 10%
body fat with a Ketogenic Diet?
And if so,
is there a daily Calorie
threshold relative to my
basal metabolic rate or other
factors to reach that level of body fat?
Also kind of another common question,
women wanting to do the ketogenic
diet to get as lean as possible.
Of course there's a lot of women in the
fitness industry or fitness competitors
that are using this approach.
So at, so the first question is,
I don't know what she's doing.
If this is for a cosmetic reasons or
if she is an athlete and wanting just
perform as optimally as
possible and thinks she gets
needs to get below 10% body
fat.
So the first question I would have for
her is why do you want to get below 10%
body fat?
So essential fat from my understanding
in women is between eight and 12% so
roughly 10% fat is needed for normal
physiological hormonal and body functions
and women.
And I think it's important to keep above
that and it's highly dependent upon the
person.
You know,
some women are just naturally very lean
and and other women have a higher set
point.
I would advise against trying to achieve
a 10% body fat for performance unless
you're genetically exceptionally
lean to begin with.
When highly trained women
at just 15% body fat,
which is very lean for women,
trains and diets to sub 10% body fat,
they tend to get these hormonal issues.
Uh,
I would call it functional
hypothalmic amenorrhea.
So it even has a term,
I believe,
I just read an article on this and
this is extremely common in the fitness
industry and, and sometimes it's
not easily, readily reversible.
So if a ketogenic diet approach is use,
it will be a greater fat turnover.
And I would advise sort of like the last
question against consuming less than
100 grams of fat.
So some of the macros that were sent to
me by women that were doing a ketogenic
diet or like 60 grams of fat,
upwards of 70 and 80 grams of fat,
and they thought that was very high.
So I would event,
I would advise against consuming
less than 100 grams fat,
especially for a female athlete.
So consuming this high level of fat keeps
your fat metabolism sort of optimized.
And uh, it also, you
know, is the source of,
of ketones is making ketones.
So probably the most
experienced individuals on
this topic achieving some 10%
body fat would be female fitness
competitors who routinely get below 10%.
And this mentioned that they do report
a lot of ministration irregularities for
women who have successfully implemented
a huge ANC diet and are aware of how to
do so. This is some of the women
that come to mind would be uh,
Shannon,
uh,
Pena or Shannon Yorkton Pena from
quest nutrition who is really a very
experienced fitness competitor and
just an overall great person around.
And she has,
um,
been in a state of Ketosis I
think for at least two years now.
And quest nutrition is
sort of developing testing.
Ultimately there'll be marketing
ketogenic diet food products.
They already have the quest MCT
oil powder, which is fantastic.
So the next question comes
from Renee volt show.
How does ketosis affect the Microbiota
specifically that balance of for making
ease to bacteria?
So that's a great question and it's
highly dependent upon the Diet that you're
following, right? It's really,
we're just at the cusp of
understanding the gut microbiome.
And there's,
so relating this question to the key to
genic diet and to give an answer on it,
it is kind of difficult because there's
many variations of the key to genic diet,
right?
The modified Atkins would be much more
liberal in the amount of vegetables that
you consume. What I've garnered
just from reading what I can, uh,
as far as studies that have been
done that and talking with, uh,
the scientists who were at this area of
research is that you can train your gut
microbiome to sort of be key to genic.
There's bacterial species in your gut.
And I don't know,
I have a list of them that
actually thrive off fat.
And these bacterial species
tend to be the beneficial ones.
They're very good for us.
So that changes dramatically.
You know,
as when we change our diet,
our gut microbiome also changes it's diet
and we'll adjust the ratios of various
species in the gut and a shift towards
more bacterial species that thrive off
fat. My general recommendations, uh,
to optimize the microbiome and my
knowledge is nowhere near that of,
you know,
researchers out there like Alessio Fasano.
I'm just the chair of pediatrics
at Harvard Medical School. Uh,
he actually gave it
fantastic IHMC lecture.
So IHMC is the Institute for Human and
machine cognition lecture on this topic.
So I would recommend that listeners
go to that lecture and uh,
and look up, uh, Alesio Fasano. Uh,
he does not study the ketogenic diet,
but he's the leading expert and most
knowledgeable person out there on the gut
microbiome.
So for those following a ketogenic diet,
things that I think could optimize the
microbiome would be sort of the obvious
things we always talk about or
hear about would be probiotics.
So green vegetables,
preferably in a raw form,
salads, things like
asparagus, trying to think.
Artichoke cinnamon is kind
of prebiotic and probiotics.
So lactobacillus Bifidus,
there's a number of other bacteria
out there that could be supplemented,
don't have,
I don't feel like the cute Jank diet
would compromise the gut microbiome in any
way, even in those
individuals that limit their,
their fiber.
So I haven't heard that that's
been a problem for them,
but to prevent it from being a potential
problem they use of these prebiotics
and probiotics,
fermented foods,
things like sour cream are part of my
diet and it's important to pick a sour
cream that has a good compliment
of a live cultures in it too.
Another thing that people
have emailed me about,
and I think Rhonda Patrick
Actually mentioned this to
me in passing and a couple
people emailed me about the
benefits of a supplement.
It's called V s l three or
VSL number three supplement.
And I think that, uh, I
haven't taken it myself,
but just from the number of emails
I got from people who have taken the
supplement and they've taken
it with a ketogenic diet,
not that they had problems
before the ketogenic diet,
but they felt that it was a good
compliment to the key to genic diet.
The VSL three supplement
is a probiotic supplement.
It's used for people, people with
Crohn's disease, Colitis, IBS,
if you've used an antibiotic,
which I just did,
actually just finished
a course of antibiotics.
I got a strange bug bite and southeast
Asia that sort of got infected in was
like Murcia.
Uh,
so I took a full course of antibiotics
and use a probiotic supplement that was
similar to VSL number three and
had absolutely no issue with,
uh,
any kind of gut problems.
And typically the last time I use an
antibiotic was over 20 years ago and it
completely destroyed my
gut. And this time, uh,
I took a probiotic supplement
and had absolutely no problems.
I don't know if I would have had
problems if I didn't take the supplement,
but it helped.
And to a probiotic supplement,
males would be good. I guess the lesson
I learned and when you travel to,
when you move someone to a different
location and there for any sufficient
amount of time, weeks, you, you're
changing their gut microbiome.
And I think that really
needs to be studied.
And I think in general we
need to understand and we
need to understand if the
ketogenic diet disrupts the microbiome.
And we have to understand
if things like travel, uh,
can disrupt the microbiome.
I imagine there's many things that
are disruptors of the gut microbiome.
And, uh, as we start to do research,
I think these things will
be more clear and, uh,
things that can optimize the microbiome.
And I think probably more importantly,
even for our servicemen,
and I knew the Department of
Defense is interested in this.
NASA judged in this obviously the
space environment, it's probably not,
uh,
or putting guys and you know,
moving them continuously across the
globe is probably not the best way to
optimize the gut microbiome. But, uh,
there's also questions like
things like artificial sweeteners,
if we're drinking chlorinated water,
antibiotics in our food,
so many things to consider when we
consider the gut microbiome. So,
relating back,
I went off on a tangent,
but when it comes to the key to
genic diet and the gut microbiome,
we still have a lot to learn,
but recommendations would be
to have a diverse diet, uh,
as much as possible.
And from my understanding,
the bacteria,
there's going to be a bacterial shift
from carbohydrate thriving bacteria to
bacterial species that
thrive off fat. So, and my,
uh, from my understanding,
that's not a negative thing.
So the next question
comes from Mary to Kala,
Adi and she asks,
currently she's currently on
the QT Jank Diet. However,
she's confused,
should I count my calories?
I'm definitely restricting my
carbs and increasing my fat intake.
But keeping track of calories along with
meal planning seems overwhelming if I
don't worry about calories a,
will I gain weight on the
key to genic diet? So yes,
of course you will. So there's
that simple thermodynamics. If you,
if you're putting in more
calories into your body,
then you're burning off those surplus
calories are going to end up, uh,
as stored body fat or manifests itself
and sort of metabolic derangement over
time. A number of times, uh, when
people transition to a ketogenic diet,
they will,
you know,
just kind of go crazy with some of the
ketogenetic diet foods that are sort of
indulgent.
And that would be things like
butter or sour cream or you know,
I can sit down with a bag of macadamia
nuts or cashews and policy that off
pretty quick. You know, that's
a thousand plus calories.
And this is really important
to understand. The Keytruda,
the energy density of the Ketogenic Diet
is about twice that of a normal diet.
So the amount,
the volume of food that you're eating
is smaller and it may seem like you're
restricting.
So then the volume of food that's on your
plate will be much less than when you
are not on a kid. Think Diet if
you're keeping it ISO cohort.
But chances are that
over time that you'll,
you'll inadvertently self
restrict on the kid genic diet.
So your blood glucose will be,
there's far less fluctuations.
You won't have these big postprandial
excursions and your glucose that kickoff a
surge of insulin that make you
hypoglycemic, you know, a few hours later,
uh,
and make you kind of craving
another Bolus of food again.
So that sort of whole cycle is eliminated
and that was really eliminated in me.
Probably one of the most practical
advantages that I've been able to realize
from the ketogenic diet is the,
the control of hunger.
And I think that has a huge carry over
effect when it comes to being able to
have control of your food intake.
And not having your food
intake sort of control you.
So tracking is a very tedious process,
but after you do it,
after a certain point,
you really don't have to.
I can look at a piece of meat or oil or,
uh,
some green vegetables on my plate and
just calculate the macros in my head
really.
And sometimes I'll just sort of wait it
out and do it in double checks and times
to make sure I'm right.
But it's not a just nowadays it's
after you follow the ketogenic diet,
it's not a laborious process.
A one trick I've learned
is that before dinner,
which is my main meal of the day,
I'll have a bowl of soup and it kind
of soup that I have is usually broccoli
cream soup or cream of mushroom soup.
And instead of using whole dairy cream,
I used concentrated coconut milk
in place of the dairy cream. So,
uh, and I thin it out so it's
not super dense in calories.
But after eating that,
the amount of food that I want to
consume this like cut in half. Uh,
obviously that, that's a lot of calories
too. But, uh, it's really super cute.
Agentic so the next
question comes from Dominic.
A bushman is his name and he asks,
how do you feel about the usual crappy
food served at scientific conferences?
And in parentheses, the smartest people
seem to have the worst lifestyle.
And he asked,
what are my nutritional tricks?
Just survive attending these
scientific conferences,
which I'm about to jump on a plane now
and go to a scientific conference in
Europe. And I know that the foods are
going to be very tempting over there.
Um,
in Budapest,
actually a very good food over there.
Luckily it's pretty key to Quito friendly.
So I am not a purist when it comes
to really fallen occasioning die.
So if someone was to follow me around
when I'm traveling and looking at what I'm
getting off the menu,
they probably wouldn't think I'm falling
any kind of weird dietary patterns.
Uh,
I,
you can almost always get a salad and
you can almost always asked for extra
butter, extra olive oil, uh,
to put on the chicken beef
or fish that it put on salad.
Um, but generally a limit
dairy protein when I'm home,
but we'll indulge a little bit when I'm
traveling. Of course, cheeses, ketogenic.
Um, so my, my recommendations
for what I do, uh,
as I've probably mentioned before is
that my bags are packed now and I have a
case of sardines in a case of oysters
and they are packed in a extra virgin
olive oil.
Um,
and I also go to a store near me and
I buy bulk macadamia nuts and I think
macadamia nuts are agree with me more
than almonds and other types of nuts.
Yeah.
The conferences that I attend,
they actually do have an appreciation for
nutrition and they had fantastic array
of food there. Other conferences, not
so much, but I think, you know, it's,
it's always people,
people say,
I can't follow the ketogenic
diet because you know,
on the businessperson I'm
traveling all the time.
It's just not possible for me to
follow this diet. So what should I do?
I think it's actually easier.
The ketogenic diet is far easier to follow
if you are that kind of person who's
on the move all the time.
So that the food that you're
consuming as much more energy dense,
it's less weight, it's less things
that you have to carry in your bag.
Sardines and oysters and macadamia nuts
take up a very small amount of weight,
relatively speaking, and they
have a really high energy density.
So I can,
uh,
I tend not to like to take
a check bag when I travel.
Just scientific conferences,
I can bring, uh,
just my carry on and get,
and if calculated this,
I can get about 10,000 calories a,
you know,
a food on my carry on really easily
and kept all my clothes for a week.
So I couldn't do that if I
wasn't on occasion and Diet. So.
So the next question
comes from Willie men,
do stimulants eight and Ketosis.
And are there any particular
stimulants that are good? Yeah,
I think caffeine has a
ton of research behind it.
The military is a big fan of caffeine
and the military has a really high bar in
regards to,
uh,
in regards to their safety in regards
to their efficacy and their incorporated
into different food products. Like,
uh, let me say the first trash,
if first strike ration is something,
you know,
that they make up their in Natick on
that feeding center there and it's
basically just sugar and caffeine.
So I think they need to change that.
But caffeine has long
been a staple in my diet,
in the form of coffee.
Um,
right now the sipping
on my coffee with MCT,
the caffeine is just
starting to kick in and,
and I feel it and I feel good on caffeine
and I don't feel any negative effects
from it.
Over 200 milligrams of caffeine
in me raises my blood sugar.
A 100 milligrams seems
to be the sweet spot. Uh,
200 milligrams of caffeine will cause a,
an overactivation of the sympathetic
nervous system maybe produce some anxiety
and it tends to caffeine mobilizes
free fatty acids from adipose,
but it also kind of breaks
down glycogen from the liver.
If my glucose is sitting at 70 70 and
I take 200 milligrams of caffeine,
I'll see a bump up to
75, maybe even 80, uh,
with that amount of caffeine.
But a hundred milligrams seems to
be a good sweet spot for me. Uh,
there's caffeine is an appetite.
Suppression has antioxidant effects in
the form of coffee and have a couple of
papers on my desk. I started
reading about the, uh,
the effects of coffee on liver function
to an improvement in liver function.
So another stimulant that
I like to talk about,
and that used a lot when I was younger,
uh,
is a federal and ephedrin hydrochloride.
I don't know if it's so available. Uh,
it's, it's, we use it in the lab.
We did experiments on
pseudoephedrine and CNS,
oxygen toxicity.
You know,
divers will pop lots of sudafed before
they go diving because he went their
sinuses to, to be clear. So they
can equalize, right. If you're not,
if you can't equalize,
if you reserve a whole day to go diving
and you're stuffed up and you can't
equalize, then you're, you're out of luck.
You know, you can't, you can't dye it.
It's too painful and
can be really dangerous.
So ephedrine is actually pretty big
in the diving community. I mean,
I always took it before I went diving
that we did a study showing that ephedrine
can actually decrease latency to seizure,
uh,
at a particular level of hyperbaric
oxygen that would stimulate the navy seal
dive to say 130, two feet
of seawater. So you're,
you're getting an overstimulation of the
brain, uh, with, with a federal and uh,
so I think with, with a high
dose, so that's the thing.
It's all relating to the dose.
I think ephedrine is a great stimulant
that could aid ketosis and it can help
the release of fat from
adipose and enhanced Beta
oxidation of fat in the liver.
Personally, I've seen that a federation
can kick me into ketosis pretty fast.
And ephedrine, caffeine stack, uh,
it can kick on a fib in some people.
So especially at the dose gets high,
you know, 50 milligrams or more per day,
but 25 milligram, those
to the federation, uh,
or less per day can elevate your mood,
can cause pretty significant
noticeable appetite suppression.
And it's more of a,
a psychological effect when it comes
to getting a physiological response.
50 milligrams,
200 milligrams a day of ephedrine to
get a really measurable increase in fat
oxidation rates.
And that would give me side effects.
So, and again, I don't, I don't even,
I'm not sure if the veteran is to legal,
so don't,
don't take this as a recommendation,
but I think 25 milligrams
of ephedrine can, uh,
improve your adherence to a nutritional
protocol just simply by suppressing your
appetite and giving you more energy,
which you're going to go
wanting to go workout,
you're going to want to exercise longer.
Um,
and I would strongly advise
against the use of amphetamines.
I don't see they're addictive
and generally people who
take these things just
have a bad outcome. They get
addictive too, if not physiologically,
psychologically. Uh,
Modafinil is something.
Uh, I've kind of been
interested in testing and I've,
but I've never taken it, but I've
talked to people who have taken it.
Um,
I did get an email just yesterday actually
from a woman who's been on Modafinil
for over 15 years continuously,
and she was able to get
off of it. And, well,
she had a narcolepsy I think, but
she was able to get off of it, uh,
when she got into a state of
nutritional ketosis and, um,
and wrote me a kind of a really nice
email along emails just saying that, uh,
like this basically the key Jank die.
It kind of saved her from this
continuous abuse. She thought,
you know, her use of Modafinil was sort
of more or less like an abuse of it for,
for many years.
So it's approved for military
use and before mission.
And so in a state where sleep deprivation
is unavoidable and you need to
maintain cognitive resilience,
the use of Modafinil can be a good idea.
Tim Actually asked me to,
uh, to address this question,
can a vegetarian or Vegan
follow a Ketogenic Diet?
You can look up.
Beth is you peck.
Kenya is the lead dietician
for the Charlie Foundation
and it may not be posted
on the website,
but I know she works
directly with patients.
Uh,
and customize is a vegetarian or even
Vegan ketogenic diet and many of her
patients and uses,
uh,
to achieve ketosis shoes as
higher amounts of MCT oil.
So there's a couple websites too that I
noticed who did a quick search online,
Kido motive,
k e t o m o t ivy and Keto Diet App are
two websites that I find were really
helpful in regards to listening to
foods and listing the type of different
recipes that are vegetarian
or Vegan ketogenic diet
could be sort of adjusted to
how do we help people that are
Vegan follicular Cenk Diet.
And I think the solution,
the main problem would be the protein.
It's just hard to put together foods
that have a compliment of essential amino
acids.
So you could just supplement
with essential amino acids
and that's one option.
And the other option would be plant
based protein isolates that are hemp.
You have,
you have rice protein isolate,
you have a pea protein isolate.
No,
10 years ago there was plant protein
but it had a lot of carbs in it.
And nowadays you can get 30
grams of protein with like
one or two or maybe three
grams of carbs.
And that completely fits in with uh,
a Vegan ketogenic diet.
So one of the products that kind of stood
out and it just looking at the reviews
and,
and with the taste on the macro nutrient
profile would be a product called Mrm
veggie elite protein powder.
And the chocolate Mocha is very good.
So if you take this a Mrm veggie elite
protein powder and mix it with coconut
cream or what,
what would be concentrated coconut milk
throw and a half of avocado or in some
MCT oil,
the ca oil and do it.
So the little mixture that I made up was
80% of the calories were from fat and
25% of the calories were from protein.
So it just titrate.
It is just like one scoop
of protein powder, I think.
And a in 15% of the calories were from uh,
carbohydrates and it was
really pretty much fiber,
a high fiber carbohydrates.
So this gives a ratio
of two to one if we go.
So two would be fat. And the one would
be a combination of carbs and protein.
So if we're kind of relating it back to
the classical Johns Hopkins ketogenic
ratio ratios that they use
and it's 900 calories and,
and that was a really good kind of example
of a pure Vegan and I posted that on
my Facebook yesterday. So yeah,
the Ketogenic Diet as possible,
pretty easy for your vegetarian, a
little more difficult for Vegan. Uh,
I'm gonna work on this and maybe even
work with a colleague of mine to write a
book that covered this subject.
And if someone hasn't kind of
written book already, I see some,
some blogs on online,
but not a whole lot of resources out
there for vegans that want to do with
kitchen jank diet. So many
people. The next question,
should I be concerned if the key to genic
die increases my LDL or Ldl particle
number? Uh, I'm a little, little bit
concerned and I'm still learning about it.
But if your LDL or Ldl p skyrockets and
stays elevated after several months,
uh, you might want to be concerned
about it. So or just kind of be more,
pay more attention to tracking
certain aspects of your,
your uh, your health, particularly your
inflammation in your blood lipid levels.
So the number of LDL particles maybe
increase because you're also carrying more
triglycerides before you get a lipid
profile test done and you start looking at
these numbers, make sure that you're
rested, make sure you're not stressed,
make sure you don't have any kind of
infection, which will increase it.
So what I think seeing with the kids,
I think diet is that the LDL
will go up and about 50% of the,
the,
the people who follow a ketogenic diet
and especially at the calories are not
restricted. So if you're restricting
calories on a ketogenic diet,
which many people do that use the diet
to manage for the management of epilepsy
or cancer.
Uh,
even in that population with accused
bank Dai is sort of calorie restricted.
About 25% of them will
sort of email back and say,
well, my doctor is following
me and this is going up.
But a lot less if calories are
restricted, uh, see this phenomenon.
So I think it's important not to stressed
out about it and to kind of look at
the big picture.
So the first book I had was
the book from Johns Hopkins,
uh,
that was written by John Freeman and
Erick Coats off and that described,
you know,
the classical kind of a dairy
based four to one ratio,
classical ketogenic diet.
Uh,
and that kind of shifted my
numbers in interesting ways. My,
my LDL went up a suited,
my HDL doubled almost from like 50 to
almost a hundred after about four to six
months, I think. So
right now my HDLs 98 my,
or right now I've,
I've transitioned into what I call a
supplemented modified Atkins or modified
ketogenic diet and supplemented because
they do take in c eight and I do take in
some exemptions,
ketones in the form of some of the
products that are on the market.
I'll talk about that a
little bit more. Uh, so I'm,
I'm using a supplemented
modified ketogenic diet
similar to the macronutrient
ratios that's described, you
know, on the, on the website, uh,
Billy foundation website
has a description,
a good description of the
modified ketogenic diet.
My ratio is looking pretty good.
My total cholesterol to HDL ratio is like
2.4 right now for my last blood test.
So my total cholesterol is
two 38 and my HDL is 98.
Triglycerides range from 40 to 70.
He's numbers are really similar to other
people that have emailed me that were
concerned.
And my inflammation
marker of inflammation,
CRP was really low.
I'm going to do a whole cytokine ask.
Say when I was on a high carb diet,
my CRP was two,
2.4 a couple of times.
Now it's like 0.2.
So literally in the last three
blood work, uh, that are looking,
looking at now, uh, it
ranged from 0.1 to 0.3.
So when I was on a high carb diet,
it's literally 10 times higher,
rarely have gotten sick when
I'm on the Ketogenic Diet.
And I do think that it
helps with immune function.
And that's another area I
could talk about. You know,
we talk about the ketogenic diet being
kind of a panacea for everything.
It cures the common cold. A,
uh, I have not had a cold,
probably,
maybe one cold in the last six years
and I used to routinely get a cold every
year at least once or twice a year.
So in the last five years,
I have one cold that I
could remember, but, uh,
infection I did get,
I traveled overseas,
I believe it was to hung bureaus and I
picked up some kind of stomach bug or
probably a virus, I think. And um,
and this really skyrocketed my LDL.
So we talked a little bit
about stress and infection,
sort of increasing that and that,
um,
it was really surprising. I mean,
it was like a, like off the charts.
So it may have been sort of, you know,
something wrong with the test, but, um,
but I think something to consider
that when you do get these tests done,
you want to make sure your
body is truly at baseline. Uh,
when you're looking at the
effects of the key to genic diet.
So in general,
I would not be concerned with an elevated
LDL unless it was in other biomarkers.
We're,
we're also out of whack.
So the things to look at would
be your triglycerides, your CRP,
and if your HDL goes down,
that's not a good thing.
I think thing that I kind of
focus on most is triglycerides.
If your triglycerides are elevated,
that means your body's just not adapting
to the ketogenic diet. You know,
some people's triglycerides are elevated
even with their calories are restricted
and that's a sign that, you know, you're
just the Yank die. It's not for you.
So you can't deny that and just,
it's not a one size fits all diet.
Do you find about a quarter to a
third of people just, you know,
have these abnormalities in their blood
work that would indicate they're not
adapting to the Diet? Maybe
they could give it more time,
but, um, it's some people,
you know,
I've given it three to four months
and still have elevated triglycerides.
Pretty rare.
And you know,
most of the people that I talked to
kind of thrive on a ketogenic diet,
but you do have many people who
just, you know, should not follow it.
The next kind of branch of questions and
I'm going to address would be exogenous
ketones.
This is a question that popped up
recently and it comes from Carson row.
Dozens of people have
asked me this question,
so I want to address it right up front.
So is it dangerous to use ketone
salts which are receiving WIC?
So there's, uh, the ketone salts
that are on the market. Now,
from my understanding,
uh,
have a d and an l configuration.
Dr. Richard Veech on,
he was a ketone expert on bulletproof
podcast and Dr Veech said that he would
avoid ketone salts at all costs.
Something about real verse
mimicked molecules, et Cetera,
is dom and others like Patrick Arnold
have said, these are good and fine,
uh, what gives, what's going
on? So, so Dr Veatch's,
uh,
I admire for like Dr Veech was kind of a
mentor to me getting into this area and
I think it was back in 2008
I didn't even know that.
2008 and nine I didn't know that exogenous
ketones existed until I found some of
his patents and patents that
even predated his were from, um,
Dr Henri Brunon grabber at Case Western.
I think the first was like a Canadian
patent in the early nineties on a ketone
ester.
So Dr Veech has been sort of a mentor
to me in this process and making,
helping me understand sort of the
benefits of exotic gems, ketones.
So his comments on they've Asprey's
podcast and more recently been greenfield
pause podcast have created a lot of
confusion because his comments were not
scientific fact,
they were his opinion.
And that's really important
to keep in mind. Uh,
also keep in mind that Dr Veech
has a lot of intellectual property,
sort of tied up in the,
are an antitumor of the ketone ester.
So more specifically the r one,
three butane dial,
our Beta hydroxybutyrate Mano
Esther would be like the means,
sort of like this single Esther
that he's focused on. Uh,
so the,
the appearance of these
ketone salts and the salt,
the Beta hydroxy butyrate is not,
you know,
completely tied up with sodium.
So it's actually balanced across four
different monovalent and divalent Ken
Ions, right? You have a sodium,
potassium, calcium and magnesium, um,
that many of these products are using like
the key gen x product. And I think, uh,
prove that product.
I'm not exactly sure what the blend is,
but uh,
but Dr Veech is kind of critical about
the sodium content and about the,
the uh,
what he called the non-natural
isomer that was found in there.
It could, a new doctor beaches is
working very hard to commercialize.
He's been working hard for a decade or
more to commercialize the mono ester of
the,
our Beta hydroxybutyrate.
So unrewarding grabber
who is features colleague,
they've actually published together,
demonstrated the metabolism of [inaudible]
ketones and a number of elegant
studies. He actually used a,
these are tracer based studies,
were sort of labeled the carbons,
the ketones and could see where they go.
And it was clear from
the science that the,
the s an antitumor just simply goes,
gets broken down to a cdot
Kobe and can even enter,
convert back to buy sort of further
elevating levels of Acetol coa that can
actually kind of feed back into
the biosynthesis of the our Beta
hydroxybutyrate.
And uh,
there's a couple of Nice papers that
kind of show that. The first one, uh,
the one that I'm thinking about looked
at the r and the s one three butane dial
metabolism in the liver of rats.
There's no data to support.
Dr Veech is claim that the ketone salts
that are on the market are dangerous or
ineffective and that would
include Quito sports.
Kido CAINA prove its product. Uh, k o,
uh,
you have the key gen x product is also
using the rear simic salt forever green
has product.
He tonics are key.
Topia so many emails,
dozens,
if not hundreds of emails I've
gotten from it, from this,
the people that were
concerned. Uh, and it's,
it's kind of easy.
The doctor of each is a very esteemed
kind of researcher and I think he firmly
believes that the are an antitumor is um,
sort of the way to go when it comes
to exogenous ketones. And I did too.
I think our lab,
actually,
the first ketone ester that we tested
for CNS oxygen toxicity was the one three
butane dial, uh, uh,
Beta hydroxybutyrate mono
ester and the RN and tumor.
And it didn't prevent
oxygen toxicity seizures,
so elevated pretty much
exclusively Beta hydroxybutyrate.
And um,
I was going to give up on the project and
then I discovered an earlier patent by
Henri burning grabber that had a one
three butane dial combined with a cdot
acetate. And that to me it made perfect
sense, right? Because when you consume it,
the it hydrolyzes in your gut.
So you released to Acetoacetate and that's
one of the ketones at the body uses.
And then the one three butane dial,
um,
goes to the liver and gets broken down
completely to Beta hydroxybutyrate.
And the pharmacokinetics are beautiful.
You get a kind of a one to one ratio of
Beta hydroxybutyrate and acetoacetate
and the liver.
And it was in that particular ketone
Ester gave remarkable neuroprotection
against CNS oxygen toxicity.
So that was like the second ketone Ester
that we tested a Patrick Arnold's help
me synthesize it.
And once we got the synthesis formula
and unrewarding grabber was very kind to
just give it to me in and tell us
how to do it too. And that was rare.
Simic so that was received
Mc one three butane dial,
which breaks down to the, the two
enantiomers of Beta hydroxybutyrate.
So it was remarkably
effective in our hands. So I,
I knew there was more to the story
than this. Um, I'm also, you know,
served with Dr Veech on various
workshops and can say that he's very,
uh, he's very opinionated when it comes
to the key to genic diet and he thinks to
diet is sort of a horrible diet
and the high fat is very dangerous.
And, uh, and we know that
that's not the case, you know,
and there's not a whole lot of
science to back up his claim.
But I think there's one paper in kids in
Johns Hopkins that followed the four to
one sort of classical key to genic diet.
And I think many of the kids were
put on a product called Keto cow,
which is like hydrogenated
vegetable oils and things like that.
And they had an elevated triglycerides.
Not very surprising. Right. Uh,
so I think when we talk about
the ketogenic diet, it's,
it's really important to acknowledge,
and most people don't acknowledge this
in the medical community that the Diet,
there's many,
many versions of the Diet and we still,
we have very little research.
We still need to determine the
optimal key to genic diet, uh,
in regards to the fatty acid profile.
So we know we need it.
A much greater omega three to Omega six
ratio is going to be really important.
The, the level of mono unsaturated
fats for saturated. Um,
I'll say that no scientist
when it relates to the,
the ketone salts,
no scientists are toxicologists that I'm
aware of would find to be just comments
to be true that the receive,
make salts are dangerous in any way,
unless of course they're consumed
at really high amounts. As we know,
water is toxic in high amounts.
All things are dangerous.
Caffeine of course I talked about
a Tylenol, we'll quickly kill you.
Uh, if you take too much of it. Um,
many studies actually show,
there's clinical studies that actually
show these receiving salts are very safe
in high doses,
even in kids given pure sodium Beta
hydroxybutyrate over periods of years.
And that actually leads me to the next
question that was asked by Emily bent and
she asked what's dawn's advice for fatty
acid oxidation disorders like mad or
VLC add a medium chain are very long
chain Acetol coa dehydrogenase deficiency.
So mad,
uh,
is short for multiple esal
Kobe dehydrogenase deficiency.
And since being added
two new gorn screenings,
diagnosis have increased massively.
So there's a lot of kids,
more kids being diagnosed.
So the complications of this particular
disorder can involve and acidosis the
hypoglycemia. Other symptoms
such as general weakness, uh,
enlargement of the liver, enlargement
of the heart is really a problem.
So essentially what this disorder,
multiple ACL co a
dehydrogenase deficiency is,
is a mitochondrial inefficiency.
And it's interesting if you just go
to pub med and type in mad m a d d and
ketones,
you get a,
this is one just one of the disorders
that can be effectively treated with
receipt.
Mick Beta hydroxybutyrate salts
and there's a number of studies.
Um, I'm just going to pub
med now. First study pops up,
highly efficient ketone body treatment
and multiple acyl coa dehydrogenase
deficiency related leukodystrophy.
So,
and that was published
in pediatric research.
So that was using the ketone salts
essentially that are on the market,
at least the sodium [inaudible],
sodium Beta hydroxybutyrate assaults
and these kids, it's a nice description,
a summary of that.
Uh,
another study by a different investigator,
a favorable outcome after physiological
dose of Sodium d l three hydroxybutyrate
and severe Matt.
So sodium receive Mech,
Beta hydroxy butyrate was given.
And this can be given in an oral dose or
it can be given ivy in very high doses
and no,
No side effects from this.
The dose that you need to get a miserable
boost in blood key tones is not giving
you a dangerous dose of sodium.
So that needs to be acknowledged.
And I think that was touched upon in
Dr Veech has sort of talk to that.
There's no way I think quote unquote,
he said there's no way that these ketone
salts could even increase ketones even
0.1 or 0.2 millimolar.
But that's not the case.
We know that we can get levels into
the one to $2 million range if you take
enough.
And I think as the technology sort of
evolves and we're creating various types
of Beta hydroxybutyrate salts from
monovalent and divalent con cannons in
addition to alkaline amino acids will
combine nicely with Beta hydroxybutyrate
and that's another avenue.
So you can kind of envision a blend
of Beta hydroxy buttery spread across,
you know,
monovalent divalent,
cad ions and alkaline amino acids
like lysine and arginine history,
histamine, a stitch or
lean. These are all,
these are all combined pretty nicely
with the Beta hydroxy butyrate.
So another study actually
comes from the Lancet shows DL,
three hydroxy butyrate.
So receive Beta hydroxybutyrate
treatment as a sodium salt,
uh, and treatment of multiple ACL
Kobe dehydrogenase deficiency.
So it's a really nice study
describing the use of uh,
this exogenous ketone and several
patients that have this disorder.
And it was really, um, highly
effective in treating that. So,
so in short,
the ketone salts,
there were simic Beta hydroxybutyrate
salts are not dangerous and they're
definitely not ineffective or research
needs to be done on all forms of
exogenous ketone salts and also,
uh,
exogenous ketone esters.
So a lot of work has already been done.
You know,
one could be more confident in,
you know,
the medical applications of this and
even potential performance applications
because when they're consumed,
the liver function and
kidney function is normal,
has been shown even
with really high doses.
So the next question is Jeff Urbane,
is he truly behind?
Involved in Ketogenics?
The website is kind of sketchy and the
product itself has a surprising number of
carbs, not sugars, carbs, but obviously,
uh,
but still,
so he's asking am I behind?
He genex are involved in key genex.
The key genics formula or product on
the market uses the exonerees ketone
product is a great product. I use
it myself. I used it yesterday.
Sometimes I rotate, you know,
different things. If I'm testing a,
it uses a ketone formula,
a Beta hydroxybutyrate medium
chain triglyceride blend
that we sort of developed
and tested initially in the lab.
And we found,
we found that if you just take ketone
salts and at the time these were sort of
the liquid sodium potassium salts,
uh, founding Keto force, uh,
we weren't really able to get
an elevation of blood ketones.
That was really impressive.
And before we started getting some
GI discomfort and diarrhea, so,
uh,
we started tweaking and playing around
with different formulas and found that if
we took medium change triglycerides
and blended it together,
we got a formula that
the fat essentially was,
was functioning like a
controlled delivery system.
So instead of,
uh,
the rapid peak was a little less
rapid but kept going up peak,
they're around 60 to 90 minutes and then
extended out in additional hour or two
beyond just taking the ketone salts.
So when we blended it with MCT,
it allowed if the sustainment
of blood ketones over time,
which is kind of the big thing.
And that's why, you know,
with the kids that were administered
a sodium Beta hydroxybutyrate,
they were given ivy formulas,
um,
the Gi sometimes to tolerate it.
And when you bowl a sit in, eh,
the blood levels shoot up and quickly
come down fat and fiber and protein,
even fat as especially is a good
sort of controlled delivery system.
And there's ways to even package that
and formulate it to optimize that.
Uh, so the key gen x
product is not my product,
but they incorporate a patented
formula that we developed.
And, uh, I don't own the
patent. The university owns
the patents. So Keith genics,
as you know, his, his work with our
university to get the rights to,
so I used the product. Uh,
I don't endorse the product.
If I used,
I need to use 1.5 packets blood
into the one millimolar range.
Uh, when you take it,
you definitely feel it.
You don't want to take it after
like three or four in the afternoon,
but you take it early in the afternoon.
I'll probably take it
around lunchtime one or two.
The energy focus you
feel is definitely real.
I blood work, uh, when I've taken it
continuously to a fairly high dose,
looked really good markers of
inflammation, like almost nondetectable.
Uh,
my blood lipid profile is probably the
best it's ever been since I've been key
to genic. Uh, the carbs in
there, very minimal. You know,
what I look at is the glycemic response
to a dose and it's pretty much flat
lined in me.
So there's no vice simic response and a
nice elevation and Beta hydroxybutyrate.
Next question. Jimmy
Homan key. Genics Quito,
s Pruvit Keto cream.
Is he affiliated with
these, uh, like they claim,
if not,
does he recommend them?
So I've tried all the exogenous ketone
products on the market and something I
like to do, uh, like to
figure out, you know,
what formulas are going to be optimal,
uh,
from the standpoint of using
these therapeutically too.
So I feel like I'm kind of at the
forefront of understanding what blends of
Ketone esters of ketone salts,
whether it be mineral salts and
amino acid salts and other things.
The Fun comes in for me is when you
start combining these things together and
that's what we're doing now and we're
doing mostly a lot of pharmacokinetics and
toxicology work.
They understand like what would
be the optimal formula of blend?
Like is it, you know, five
different types of salts with,
you know, to Esther's in a different
ratio. Like these are with some,
uh,
c eight oil to sort of increased and
sustained blood ketones over time.
Like these are the questions that we're
asking and some of the things that we're
testing now, I think the Pruvit
product tastes really good.
It's smooth and creamy and it has a
higher concentration of sodium in much
higher. And maybe that's why it's
because kind of like the salty,
creamy taste I love. I kind
of ran out of it. I miss it.
I using it for a while
and they ran out. So, uh,
right now I'm using
the key genics product,
which is really sort of pretty
powerful product as far as the uh,
effects that I feel from it.
So the key genics product instead
of kind of a creamy taste,
it has more of a Tangy, bitter taste.
It's got some green tea extract.
So the caffeine, it does give you
a little bit of a caffeine boost,
maybe about 80 to a hundred
milligrams of caffeine.
And I think that's from
the green tea extract.
It might be some bitter orange in there.
There's a couple thermogenic
ingredients in there that uh,
you feel after you take the product
cause he feel a little bit warm for
evergreen, makes the, uh, key tonics
product. It tastes really good.
And I think it also gives a,
has caffeine in the form of green tea too.
It's pretty similar to the
key genics product. Uh,
just has a different taste
to keep in mind that the,
the early versions of these
products were like horrible.
This is going back. Uh, and I
used to blend them, actually.
I blended,
uh,
a mixture out and gave it
to my friend Peter Attia.
And Peter wrote a nice,
kind of a great summary of his
experience with using jet fuel.
Uh,
he's tested a lot of these things that
ketone esters in the ketone salts and did
the study on the bike where he looked
at oxygen consumption at a fixed power
output,
clamped it at 180 watts and then
look the oxygen consumption before,
uh, exogenous ketones. And after,
and at the time Peter was doing a,
a sort of a modified ketogenic approach.
So he was in a state of mild
nutritional Ketosis, like 0.6,
0.7,
and he would take,
he took the ketone salts and it shot
him up about one to two millimolar and,
uh,
kind of dosed him up with a blend
that I knew would be approaching the,
his Gi tolerability. And I think
he did okay. Didn't have any,
they didn't throw up or have diarrhea
from my understanding. And uh,
they really cranked it out on the bike
and showed that he was able to maintain
the same power output
and consume less oxygen,
like a five to 8% less oxygen,
which is tremendous.
We need to go and reproduce that study.
The next question comes
from Gavin Williams.
What are his goto
products, his MCT, powders,
oils, ketone salts, anything
else? Uh, kind of covered this.
So I test whatever the company sent
me. I love to test things. I tend,
that's why I don't take a whole lot of
supplements because I like to keep a
unaltered, I guess you could say. So I can
confidently test these things and,
and,
and if I'm measuring various blood,
whether it be comprehensive blood
work or blood glucose, ketones,
I know it's coming from that product.
I really enjoy testing to prove that
product and uh, told you, you know,
I miss it now, that amount
of it. So they're listening.
They could send me some police. Uh, the
key gen x product is great. So I have a,
and that they've, I think they're on
like version two or three of that now.
The one of the first times I tried,
the last formula they gave me,
I took the product at like 7:00 PM and
kind of kept me up a little bit later
than I wanted to. Uh,
another product that's been,
that's really a goto product
and I, and I keep it, you know,
at my house at work and it's in my
suitcase when I travel is to quest MCT oil
powder and the quest coconut
powder is a big staple of mine.
Uh,
I've talked about sort of the foods that
I've consumed before the wild planet,
Sardines, sardines are uh, uh,
a much more sustainable then say like
tuna or some of the larger fish out there
that these predatory fish also,
uh,
through bioaccumulation can accumulate
toxins like mercury and other heavy
metals.
So I'm so non detectable levels of the
things that are of concern like mercury
and other, other, uh, PCBs and
other things that are out there.
So that's important,
especially if you're giving your fish to
your young kids or the oysters are also
one of my goto food through the crown.
Prince Oysters are a really
good brand that I like.
Lately there was a bone broth that I use.
It's a little pricey,
but the company kindly sent me a sample,
the test and it's called fire
and kettle bone broth. And uh,
I use it maybe like twice a week.
I'll make soup out of it
and I think it's fantastic.
I think it's super high quality.
Another goto product would be a citation,
makes a product called extend perform,
which is branch chain amino acids,
leucine,
isoleucine and failing in a
two to one to one combination.
Lucien being the predominant, uh, uh,
branch chain amino acid
in the formula that, uh,
and we know that loose scenes, a
powerful activator of m tour, uh,
which is a good thing.
Activating and tore and skeletal
muscle is really important.
So intro workout.
So I used the product
preworkout and intro workout.
I've used the product a little
bit during fast and I think, uh,
it could be an effective
tool for mitigating some
of the muscle loss that can
accompany a, uh, a longer short term fast,
if that makes sense.
So like five days or seven days.
So the extent performed product also has
a mushroom blend in it and I have to go
and look to see, uh, I actually
researched all the mushrooms,
but they're kind of
leaving me exactly which,
which blend it has in it.
But the mushroom blend that's in there
has been proven to have a pretty,
pretty impressive,
uh,
data behind it as far as enhancing,
performance and for
lowering inflammation to,
uh,
the other supplements I take sort
of like staple things would be if,
uh, if I'm not getting
a lot of sun, a d three,
so 5,000, I use sort of, if
I'm not getting sun on days
and I'm outside all day,
I take, uh, 1000, uh, I
use, so don't, you don't,
you don't want to get too much d three.
So there's a bell shaped curve and the
too much d three will give you the same
symptoms of a too little vitamin D.
So Melatonin is something that I take.
It's part of, uh, the
sleep cocktail I will take,
I use it when I cross time zones,
uh,
and I'll use up to 10 milligrams.
But for daily use I will use like
anywhere between one to three or five
milligrams, typically like three
milligrams I think is what I have. Um,
so I debit known is a,
another product that I take a,
I take it when,
uh,
I fly actually or before hard exercise.
It's the,
I think of I Devin own is kind of
the drug version of coenzyme Q 10.
It's more absorbable,
it gets to the Mitochondria easier.
It's like a mitochondrial
antioxidant and it's also the, it's,
it's a germ rug.
It's almost considered a drug for the
management of something called Friedrich's
Ataxia.
And I think in kids that take I and
own it actually helps him out a lot.
I'm not sure if you know, Friedrich's
Ataxia is really a tough disorder,
but I know from what I knew
and just talking with, uh,
the far foundation,
so I know a family and a child
with Friedrich's Ataxia and uh,
from the research indicates that I Devin,
Oh and prevent cardiomyopathy
or a hypertrophy.
So it just showing it has a real effect.
So just enhancing cardiac function,
uh, has been, has been shown with I
Devin know. And so, um, I think it,
it's available.
It used to be kind of hard to find
because it was reclassified as a drug,
but I think it's, I know it's available
on smart powders.com you can find it,
which a lot of really
interesting things there.
A magnesium is a supplement I
take daily magnesium citrate,
magnesium chloride and
magnesium glycinate.
I tried them all and they all impacted
my blood magnesium levels in a good way.
So when I started the Ketogenic Diet,
I started getting cramps.
So one thing that popped out in my blood
work is that my magnesium was at the
low end of normal.
And now that I'm supplementing now I'm
like a mid to high normal and I don't get
any cramps.
If I exercise more,
I definitely deplete my magnesium. So,
um, you know, if you're exercising,
just be sure that you're getting adequate
magnesium. Uh, on a QT Jank died.
I think you're, you're utilizing
more excluding more magnesium and a,
if my goat,
if I had one go to magnesium,
it would be this magnesium
citrate powder that I have.
So I,
I've looked at things like
a Gabba a before sleep,
sometimes Finny Butte, which is
ventilated Gabba Gabba that has a,
a fennel ring attached to it and makes
it permeable to the blood brain barrier
and makes it more lipophyllic.
And when you take Finny Butte,
you feel it. I feel it. You feel much
more calm. You get, I get really deep,
the most scary dreams when
I take take fenny Butte. Uh,
it has a pretty good calming effect.
So I will use Finny Butte maybe
two or three times a month if that,
you tend to use it.
When I'm travel across time zones,
I'll take a finny Butte melatonin
stack before I get to bed.
Next question. Leo. Fouls
on our exotic us ketones.
I kido Kina only useful in a state of
ketosis or would they benefit someone who
is not keto adapted,
put differently?
Can ketones enter the TCA cycle?
I'll sit in as the Kreb cycle when
glucose is still available to the cell or
will the body preferentially use glucose
nullifying the effect of the ketones.
So ketones can be readily
transported into tissues as fuel.
If glucose is low or high and I think
the body will sort of use what's
available.
So if the glucose is low,
it'll use a greater proportion
of ketones for energy.
And it's also,
there's some tissue specificity in
regards to the mono carboxylic acid
transporter and there's transporters one,
two,
three and four and these have sort
of a different tissue distributions.
Breen is pretty high and MCT two
and three I believe the liver,
you know,
doesn't use good liver.
The ketone producer but doesn't use
ketones for fuel and skeletal muscles kind
of like in between.
So Sunday at eight indicates that
there may be enhance glucose uptake and
utilization in the presence of ketones.
And I know Dr Veech and,
and others believe that ketones
influence influence sensitivity.
And it does it through
a number of mechanisms.
And I think through,
through altering redox chemistry,
it can do two things.
It can enhance the sensitivity of the
insulin receptor to the likened insulin.
And it can also cause a sort
of a translocation of the
receptor to the membrane.
And so there's more sort of
receptors that are available.
And I think,
you know,
I was a little has into
believe some of that,
but our new data we recently
published shows that as ketones go up,
and this is giving a bolus of exogenous
ketones to an animal that to eating a
high carbohydrate standard rat Chow,
glucose goes down.
And you know,
we don't know why that's happening,
but that could be part of the effect
could be enhanced with Pcos disposal
through enhancement of
insulin sensitivity and um,
and other things that we
don't fully understand.
And I think some of the data that we'll
be collecting that may shed light on
this is looking at the metabolomic
global metabolomic profile of the liver,
you know,
within without exogenous ketones and
how that's influencing liver metabolism.
So an alternative explanation could be
a decrease in hepatic gluconeogenesis.
So I think it's, it may be Bamyan number
of things kind of working together.
So Adam Rock Horst has a question,
can exogenous ketones
combined with a low carb diet,
uh, in parentheses, but
not a ketogenic diet,
still give some or all the benefits
of a strict ketogenic diet.
The experiments that we
run with exogenous ketones,
most of them excluding the one cancer
experiment when we combined the key to
genic diet with ketone ester.
So our experiments are typically run
using exogenous ketones given to animals
eating a standard high carb rodent child.
So I would say yes to this and I would
say yes because our first experiment
originally what I wanted to do was give
ketone esters for one week and dive rats
down to five atmospheres of oxygen,
which is 132 feet of seawater.
And we know that they have a seizure in
about 10 minutes and then look at that
latency to seizure.
You know,
after talking with a number of experts
and Dr Veech too thought the ketones
work,
but a number of the experts are convincing
me that you needed to be keto adapted
to get the benefits of exhaustion
is ketones that the ticket,
the optimal benefits, I'll say, you know,
and I thought they were right cause we
actually try doctor beaches, Esther, uh,
or version of the Ester,
the Mono Ester of Beta hydroxybutyrate
and it didn't prevent oxygen toxicity
seizures.
So I was more inclined to
believe at least an acute post.
I was more inclined to believe that
you needed continuous kind of longterm
dosing to get the brain to switch over.
But then we tried the a
one three butane dial,
a cdot acetate diaster,
which rapidly elevated Beta
hydroxybutyrate and a COO acid hay.
And that a single dose,
30 minutes prior to a five atmosphere
dive gave like 600% neuro protection or
delay the latency to seizure from
10 minutes to like over an hour,
which was pretty much more effective
than any anticonvulsant drug like ever
tested.
So,
and that was just simply feeding an
animal that's eating a high carb diet,
feeding him,
titrating in the dosage just enough
to elevate blood ketones to a level of
ketosis on par with a
person fasting for one week.
So you had fasting level,
prolonged fasting level
ketosis in 30 minutes.
And unlike drugs where you
get like a variety of effects,
like it worked in this
animal that not the animal,
like every single animal we tested when
we saw this remarkable neuro protection
with the ketone esters. So, so that was,
it was not my original hypothesis that it
would work this way, but it, but it did.
I guess Dr Veech was right. Uh, not right
about the Esther. I think we needed,
we needed not only Beta hydroxybutyrate,
we needed to see to acetate and his
particular Esther did not elevate that.
I think Beta hydroxybutyrate
elevating that would for his,
he's looking at um,
exercise performance and cognitive
benefits too. And I think it would work,
you know,
Beta hydroxybutyrate alone would
probably work remarkably well for that.
But when it comes to mitigating oxygen
toxicity seizures and also other
seizures, the animal models, it's,
it's very clear that you need to have
an elevation of a COO acetate and that
spontaneously decarboxylates to ask the
town and we know that can open potassium
channels in hyperpolarize the resting
membrane potential and mitigate some of
the glutamate excited toxicity
that's thought to be involved in,
in seizure genesis.
So,
and you don't get that we just
Beta hydroxybutyrate ester.
So answer your question.
Yeah,
I think you can get ketones.
I went off on a tangent and you,
she really talking about combining
exogenous ketones to a low carb diet.
Can you get the benefits?
Uh, absolutely. I think,
I think you can do that even
on a moderate carb diet.
It can probably get the benefits,
but there are so many benefits to a low
carb diet and of itself that we know
about. I think it just makes sense to
use it with some kind of carbohydrate
restriction. It is really important
and if you look at our cancer study,
we did the Ketogenic Diet and hyperbaric
oxygen and that had a remarkable effect
at prolonging survival and a
model advanced metastatic cancer.
And uh,
and when we combine the Ketogenic Diet
with hyperbaric oxygen and we combine to
ketone supplementation,
we had a really significant increase in
survival and suppression of tumor growth
and also medistatus.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com
that's four hour workweek.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll
get the very next one and if you sign
up, I hope you enjoy it. This episode
is brought to you by four sigmatic.
I reached out to these
Finnish entrepreneurs after
a very talented acrobat,
introduced me to one of their products,
which blew my mind and the best
way possible it is mushroom coffee.
What on earth is this? Well,
it includes Chaga mushroom,
very powerful antioxidant,
considered a super food.
I was introduced to
Chaga by Laird Hamilton,
the King of Big Wave Surfing of all things
and it includes another mushroom that
is considered a no tropic,
a smart drug and this is lion's
mane in the entire packet.
You just add it to hot water,
tastes like coffee.
There is only 40 milligrams of caffeine,
so less than half what you would
find in a cup of coffee. So you,
I do not get any jitters.
I did not get any acid reflux or any type
of stomach burn and it put me on fire
for an entire day and I
only had half of the packet.
So this stuff is really amazing.
People are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement right now.
This is the answer. So it is legal.
It will not give you visuals.
That's something else and you can try it
right now by going to foursigmatic.com
forward slash Tim that is for Sig s I g
m a t I c foursigmatic.com/tim and use
the Code Tim to get 20%
off your first order.
If you are in the experimental mindset.
I do not think you'll be disappointed.
foursigmatic.com/tim this
episode is brought to you
by gymnastic bodies.com this
is the training system that I am most
obsessed with at the moment and I don't
get paid any commissions
or anything like that.
You may have heard coach summer on
the podcast to design the program,
former national team coach
for men's gymnastics.
I'm not easily impressed and I've
just been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming
and the elegance of his programming.
I've been using gymnastic bodies for
just a few months now and I feel more
flexible, stronger, and
younger than I have in years,
and it sounds cheesy to hear
myself say that, but it's true.
That's the hardest part to
believe and you can check it out.
Gymnastic bodies.com forward slash
Tim if you go to that landing page,
gymnastic bodies.com forward slash Tim
you can take a look at the fundamentals
course, which I'll be diagnosed,
your weakest points, areas
to improve, et Cetera,
and I highly encourage you take a look
at this body weight training system.
It is incredible.
Gymnastic bodies.com forward slash tip.